Now before I move on let me show you.
the function 5
Which is right here, and then I'm going to show you how it works.
With Wolfram. Well, you can
use any calculator, but we will use a quote from alpha for this.
so we want
the
cumulative distribution function
of they standardized normal variable of the
normal distribution rather know what distribution
let me make sure we have the correct formula.
So there's two things we want to look at. This is number one.
one
and two
this
is
the formula for the normal distribution
and then there was one.
for the standardized
normal distribution
the normal distribution without it being standardized as this formula.
Okay, we will break down these terms.
So we know why I mean what it means, okay.
But when you standardize it.
you will get
okay.
Now when you use r
these
like the function is built into the language.
You don't actually have to
type out the expression and plug them in.
It's built in but you still need to know how they work.
and
what when you should use which one?